bon
c'est génial c'est pas assez
extraordinaire mais eux ils sont
vachement bien parce que ils perdent pas
il perd pas le sens de l'humour il
déconne ils sont vachement bon viendrait
une vraie liberté c'est un vrai plaisir
en même temps c'était un vrai stress
parce que sinon moi je ne serai pas
faire ce que je sais pas qui osent se
faire ça brad pitt est à clous 10 énorme
mais je me rends pas bien compte je
crois que je ne sois pas le faire ouais
je venais bon je suis peut-être
inconscient c'est peut-être beaucoup la
conscience aujourd'hui ont le mauvais
goût au début quad réel sur le gilet à
quoi je devais vraiment acheté ce que je
trouvais ça beau bravo bien alors n'est
ce pas ici pour ça vous êtes ici pour
votre spectacle au palais des glaces
vous savez ça rappelle à huit
changements oui mais vous savez comment
faire des petites mains attention tout
le monde le fait
one man show au palais des glaces depuis
maintenant trois mois
ça s'appelle je m'entraîne c'est du
mardi au samedi à 22 heures salle 2 oui
bon il bien démarré et quelque part
voilà rien de temps très fort dans ce
spectacle les répondeurs